Peter Desberg, Author: So when do the interesting
questions start?
Film Courage: Right now, actually.
But this [question] is a little bit leading…why
are so many screenwriters opposed to structure?
Jeffrey Davis, Author: I didn’t know they
were?
My experience is that there are two groups
of screenwriters now.
There used to be…I mean you probably remember
in the 90’s and early 2000’s, there was
the Chris Vogler book (which is pretty good
actually) and the [John] Truby book and who
is the guy who charges almost as much as the
EST seminars?
And it used to be like this is how you write
a screenplay.
And I think that particularly in TV screenplays
and teleplays, that’s changing.
I would like it…again to me…structure
is the easiest thing to learn that the craft
of it…that’s not even to me the craft
of it.
I could basically teach anybody how to structure
a screenplay.
And I’m lucky to have Peter because (I’m
not joking around) he’s really good at structure.
But I believe structure comes out of character
and conflict, so I have not against a lot
of writers who are opposed to that.
I just think what some teachers do is they
will teach structure before they teach character
or conflict which is a big mistake because
I’ve read things that are beautifully structured
and empty.
Peter Desberg: There is software now that
you can get to structure your screenplay.
Mariner makes a whole bunch of software products.
Jeffrey Davis: That’s easy.
I could teach you all of that, formatting
and structuring and all that.
But I hadn’t heard what you’re hearing.
Are you hearing that a lot of people are opposed
to structure?
Film Courage: It was a question to see what
your answer would be.
Jeffrey Davis: Well for God’s sake Karen.
I’m so disappointed.
Film Courage: Maybe it’s a rumor.
But I’m just throwing it out there.
Jeffrey Davis: It’s funny because I hear
the opposite.
I hear people fall back on structure.
Not so much TV, I guess?
Peter Desberg: There are a bunch of really
funny videos on Youtube of fake pitches.
They are hysterical.
There is a wonderful on…
Jeffrey Davis: …On pitching CITIZEN KANE.
It’s hysterical.
GONE WITH THE WIND…
Peter Desberg: I’m trying to think about
the one I really like here…PULP FICTION?
“These pages are all out of order.
So don’t worry.
We made the story flow in a logical sequence
now.
So again (I think like many other areas) the
concept of structure is evolving also.
But that started a long time ago.
That probably started in the 60’s with the
new French Novel and stuff where all of the
sudden you don’t know if you’re seeing
a sequence, whether you are seeing a composite
or which part is fantasy in someone’s head
and which part is real.
So the whole notion of structure is evolving
a lot.
So things aren’t necessarily as linear as
they were.
People are taking bigger liberties that way
(which is a good thing).
Jeffrey Davis: I think you have to write the
way that…now I’m not talking about being
in a [TV writer’s] room…then you’ve
got to observe the rules that the Showrunner
lays out.
But if you’re writing something of your
own and if for example I always tell students
and I tell myself that if you are awakened
at 3 o’clock in the morning and a scene
comes to you, get up and write it down.
And don’t worry about where it goes in the
structure.
But if you wait, you might still be able to
write the scene but it won’t have the same
power and the passion that you felt.
It woke you up for a reason.
And a lot of writer’s (mainly students)
are afraid to do that because they’ve had
pounded into your head that you must write
everything in order and that’s the part
that makes me crazy.
That’s the part that makes me crazy.
How can you write everything in order?
There’s a famous quote…I forget who said
it?
You know, I am blanking on everything today.
But I do know Franchise now.
I am not going to forget that.
“How do I know what I think until I see
what I say?”
Film Courage: Oh wow!
That’s deep.
Jeffrey Davis: Isn’t that powerful?
Film Courage: Is this what Adam has hanging
over his desk?
[Referring to this video on Pitching a TV
Series]
Jeffrey Davis: Yes…see you’ve got a new
quality for him.
I mean, I think a lot of people are afraid
to dive into…I am…to just dive into that
darkness and let it be bad and find the structure.
But make sure that you find it from the characters
because otherwise it will be empty.
Film Courage: Do you find certain students
and some of the people you’ve worked with
are okay with going to those [dark] places
and others are really (whether it’s their
upbringing) they’re scared?
Jeffrey Davis: Nobody is okay with it.
You get them to be okay with it.
And what I’m doing, I’m teaching.
I co-created a course a couple years ago (a
remade course for freshman).
And it was the first day of class (it will
be a week tomorrow).
And I said to everybody in the room “Get
ready to embrace sh*t!”
Uh oh…are you going to have to erase that?
Film Courage: No…
Jeffrey Davis: So it’s the Anne Lamott dictum
from [her bestselling book] Bird By Bird.
You have an obligation to be sh**ty.
Which you can almost see the weight come off
their shoulders.
It’s the closest I’ve feel to being like
a therapist.
I’m releasing them from the need to be good.
Because you’re going to be anyway!
You’re 18-years-old!
How good are you going to be!
And I don’t give you a good grade for being
good.
And then they go “Wait a minute?
If we try to be good you’re not going to
grade us better than people who try to be
bad?”
Exactly!
Because I don’t care, I’m interested in
the process, not the product.
You’re 18.
It doesn’t matter how good it is, it’s
still going to s*ck.
Film Courage: That word we can’t use.
Jeffrey Davis: I’m sorry.
Peter Desberg: 18?
Film Courage: Yes!
Jeffrey Davis: This is a very big thing with
me, this need people have…and I think this
is because I’m a recovering perfectionist…and
it’s another thing this partnership has
given me.
He forces me to put it down.
And if I had my druthers (not so much now,
but it used to be) I would just take forever
because I didn’t want to be bad.
Peter Desberg: Yeah…the P word is a synonym
for scared.
Film Courage: Oh…right…right.
Jeffrey Davis: I’m afraid it will s*ck and
if you tell students at the beginning “It’s
okay to s*ck.
It’s okay to be bad.”
It’s like Peter said earlier, than you have
something that’s on paper you can play with
it forever.
But if you don’t put it down, you’ve got
nothing.
Peter Desberg: We were talking about a guy
this morning who has been working for 5 years
on a screenplay.
Jeffrey Davis: 5?
10 [years].
5 I could accept.
You know it’s not like he’s writing the
great American novel, he’s writing a screenplay.
C’mon?
Really?
Film Courage: Well, unless he’s so lost
in the process…
Jeffrey Davis: Then he should be writing 3
screenplays, not 1.
Peter Desberg: Double-spaced, 12 pages a year.
I think he needs a little more output than
that.
Jeffrey Davis: I think that it is just fear
and older people have fear, too.
Film Courage: Sure…yeah.
I think it’s okay to be young and to fail.
But older people, you have to…
Jeffrey Davis: One of the worst days of my
life is the day when I finish a play or I
finish something and my first reader is my
wife because she’s an actress.
She’ll say nice things and then she’ll
say “So basically what you’re asking me
to do is put marbles in my mouth to say these
lines.”
And after I get over being hurt and thinking
about divorce court and all of those things
and I realize, you know she’s right?
Again, we are writing for actors.
We’re not writing…yes producers have to
read it.
Executives have to read it but you’re going
to be replaced really fast if you can’t
write dialogue.